jurors and Texas are sending a powerful
message to automakers about a potential
danger CBS News has reported on for
years a civil jury on Friday found clear
and convincing evidence of gross
negligence by Toyota the parent company
of Lexus it ruled the automaker failed
to warn consumers that front seats can
collapse backward during certain types
of rear-end collisions and propel people
into the seat back a verdict of more
than two hundred and forty two million
dollars stems from a 2016 crash where
two young children were severely hurt
Kris Van Cleave is in Washington and
he's been following this story
Kris good morning good morning the auto
industry has long known that front car
seats do not hold up in certain kinds of
rear-end crashes where the vehicle is
hit at a high rate of speed the injuries
to those in the backseat can be
catastrophic internal documents show the
cost to fix the problem could be on the
order of a dollar or so per seat our
children are hurt forever but we just we
can't imagine this happening to any
other families Ben and Kristi Rivas were
stopped in traffic on a Dallas area
expressway on the way home from church
in September of 2016
their two kids three year old Owen and
five year old Emily in the backseat in
their car seats when an SUV slammed into
the back of their 2002 Lexus sedan at 45
miles an hour as this crash test
simulating the collision and used during
the trial shows the front seats
collapsed sending Ben and Christie
headfirst into their own children both
kids suffered lasting traumatic brain
injuries traumatic brain injury is
devastating we have no idea what's
coming
in a statement Toyota says it respects
the jury's more than 242 million dollar
verdict but remains confident that the
injuries sustained were the result of
factors specific to this very severe
collision not a defect in the design or
manufacturing the jury understood that
the only way you were going to get any
movement here was to get Toyota's
attention and the other carmakers
throat I testified in this matter that
they had known since the eighties
attorney Frank Branson showed the jury
parts of our CBS News investigation
including this 2016 report where a jury
awarded the Rivera family more than 124
million dollars for a similar crash that
left their son with brain damage I'm
angry that I feel like we were never
given a chance to make the decision for
ourselves I wish I had have seen that
piece six months before our accident
happened because I would have started
asking questions about my own car our
investigation identified more than 100
cases where seatback collapses resulted
in serious injuries or death mostly to
children in the back seat but seats in
cars meet or exceed federal standards
for seat strength that date back to 1967
standards even a banquet chair can pass
still car makers and regulators have
known about the potential of collapses
for decades it's time to step forward
step up stand up make a decision this is
this is unacceptable now because of our
investigation several members of
Congress have called on it said it
changed the seatback strength standard
the agency has consistently maintained
at lacks sufficient evidence to take
action but is also acknowledged seatback
collapses likely underreported still
Nitsa recommends the back seat as the
safest place for kids
toyota tells us it is still considering
its next step in this case we were not
able to reach nits over the weekend
Norah Chris great reporting it's why
when I first heard about it when you
reported this a while ago so thanks for
keeping us up to date on that thank you